As hand I speak with the king's voice on
this and all other matters he's Landing then
tomorrow the high Towers land their first
blur those vipers rule in my father's name
the sea snake has taken a grave
wound in battle and stepstones who
will take the driftwood from this
is a matter of blood not ambition
this is a trap crown couldn't stand
strong at the house of the dragon
remains divided nephews the threat of War looms
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
house the dragon episode 8 trailer video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs and references
here so we'll break it down if you're brand
new to the channel I'm doing videos for all
the episodes be sure to subscribe to get them
and careful for spoilers from episode 7 if you
haven't seen it yet because we'll have to talk
about that to talk about what happens in episode
8 because there is another small time Jump like
you probably noticed that the younger actors
seem like teenagers now so I'll explain what's
happened in the missing gap of years but it's
a much smaller Gap than we've seen in previous
episodes just starting at the beginning of the
trailer and working our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs WTF moments there are
a couple major things happening in this trailer
like one you have the threat of the high Towers
taking over the Iron Throne because viserys has
become an invalid basically and they also talk
about the threat of War happening in the trailer
that references a couple different conflicts
like the actual Dance of the Dragons Targaryen
Civil War but also you have what's going on with
corlys velaryon's brother vaemond velaryon in the
stepstone there was another war with the triarchy
and possibly Dorne that they were worried about
previous episode and that's just been heating
up ever since then the only briefly addressed
that in last week's episode when laenor velaryon
was talking about his lover going back to the
stepstones because the conflict is still getting
worse it's sort of like another version of the big
war that we had in the stepstones during episode
3 but you have to remember that several years have
gone by since the last time that they actually
discussed the war during the small council like
we should probably do something about what's going
on in the stepsons no no no let's worry about it
later not a big problem now turns out later is
right now it's become a big problem so the threat
of War looms all over Westeros internally
and externally down in the stepstones and
even though it seems like the opening salvos have
been fired in the dance of the dragons because of
the big alicent versus rhaenyra fight in episode
seven it hasn't quite got to that point yet we're
a little bit closer everyone's got a little bit
older people have gotten a little bit bitter but
the all-out blacks versus greens fighting hasn't
started yet so at the beginning of the trailer
several years have gone by the kids are now
teenagers for the most part although you have to
remember that some of them were a little bit older
to begin with so like for instance aegon II was
already way older than jaecerys. So jaecerys seems
like he's a younger teenager now and it seems like
aegon II is probably approaching his 20s almost
and even though aemond one eye targaryen looks
way different way older than aegon II yet remember
that he's his younger brother he just happens to
be way taller and the years of writing vegar have
only made him more cruel I'll explain that too
because the actor who played the younger version
of him when he claimed vegar actually talked about
the switch like once he claimed vegar that changed
something inside him he changed from being this
very meek person to sort of freeing the beast so
to speak freeing this cruel person that was inside
of him but you look at alicent's children and it
just seems like the years have only made their
faces that much more punchable although it is kind
of silly to call them children because we were
watching renera and alicent being about the same
age as they were in the first couple of episodes
but it seems like what's happened in the year
since the last episode is that viserys's condition
has gotten worse and he's become bedridden
and can no longer actively rule like he would
normally expect him to do day-to-day stuff so the
fact that Otto Hightower hand and of the King has
taken over a lot of these duties isn't abnormal
like you would expect the hand of the king to do
this ages that we have the whole conflict the
dance of the Dragons going on with the blacks
versus the greens and that's what's caused them
to be worried and if you remember a long time
ago in the timeline a couple episodes ago before a
couple big time jumps ranera basically said screw
you to King's Landing in court and said let's
go to Dragonstone let's get away from all the
gossip but this is where it starts to bite them
in the ass because she hasn't been around to her
father all these years and his condition has given
the hightower's ample opportunity to try and take
control of the Iron Throne so to speak like the
way the auto Hightower is speaking in the throne
room here I speak with the authority of the king
so basically he can do whatever he wants to he has
all the power right now and it seems like that's
what brings Daemon and rhaenyra back to King's
Landing because she's probably worried about
her father and even though you do see the kids
fighting during the trailer like you see the older
version of Bayla and rhaena there as well because
obviously Daemon's gotten remarried to renera so
they move to Dragonstone as well so now you have
the Twins jaecerys and lucerys and I can't quite
tell if rhaenyra is pregnant with her first child
Daemon she might have already given birth to him
or they might save that for season two I think
they'll probably be at least like one or two more
smaller time jumps by the Time Season 2 Season 3
get going just because of how much later in the
timeline the actual Dance of the Dragons happens
and the aftermath if we're making jokes about
the kids too you could actually say that renera
and Daemon's children have gotten better looking
with time and alicent's children have actually
gotten worse looking with time like time has not
been kind to alicent's children also you have the
whole idea that aegon really liked drinking when
he was younger and that only gets worse when it
gets older that winds up affecting his long-term
health just like a little bit and obviously amen
has just gotten more and more Twisted inside as
weird as Helaena is like we know that she has
dragon dream so she's got this weird aspect about
her that they haven't fully explored yet like we
know there's something special about her because
she has dragon dreams I'm sure the years have also
made her just as much weirder it'll be real fun
to see what kind of prophecy she speaks during
episode 8. like every time we have a new episode
she speaks some new prophecies and if you couldn't
tell on the left of renera here that's jakaris her
older son luceris is later in the trailer you also
notice that they're wearing their trademark blacks
and greens because we're like that much closer
to the dance of the dragons and it is the blacks
versus The Greens that was also part of Helaena's
prophecy during episode seven when she talked
about the black and green dragons in the dragons
of thread it was meant to be a reference to the
color of the dresses that both of these women
wear they are both dragons because they're part
of the targaryen family but also it's meant to
be a reference to the dragons themselves actually
fighting each other when the actual war starts a
couple of the brand new dragons that they haven't
shown in the trailers yet but that the kids have
claims since then are baela and rhaena's dragons
obviously and lucerys' dragon. Lucerys' dragon is
named erax he claimed him normally like you would
expect them to at a young age now way back in the
timeline baela already had her dragon its name
was Moondancer rhaena was the one that wanted to
claim vhagar because she didn't have a dragon
yet but aemond and did it from under her nose
during the time jump since the last episode she's
probably claimed a dragon in that time its name is
morning but you do notice that most of the kids
on the show except for Aemond because vagar is
the oldest biggest dragon most of the kids dragons
are way smaller way younger when princess rhaenys
is saying that tomorrow the hightowers land their
first blow I think this just has something to do
with them taking control of the Iron Throne
because of viserys becoming a full-blown
invalid like maybe that just happened during the
events of this episode it also seems like Corliss
Valerian is on his deathbed he suffered some grave
injury down to the stepstones because they've been
fighting that for the last couple years I believe
this is meant to be his bedroom because in the
background it seems like it is Princess rainies at
his bedside and here's the thing about the actual
episode the title is the lord of the tides which
is a reference to the lord of House Valerian the
ruler of driftmark and there's a lot of footage of
his brother vaman Valerian in this if you remember
in last week's episode there was this whole
question of who was going to take possession
of drift Mark someday would it be luceras like
corlys thought it would be or would it be Laena's
children like rhaenys wanted it to be but you
also have to remember that vaemond velaryon,
corlys' brother has a claim to driftmark that
he's going to want to assert and he really really
hated Daemon if you remember back in episode three
like way earlier in the timeline he really hated
him that has not changed with time just when the
look on his face it just seems like he's ready to
assert his claim here he also comes marching into
the red keep with a bunch of valerian's men and
I believe the idea is that he's taking command of
their army in the stepstones in corliss's absence
there's a scene of older Criston Cole training
with older Aemond Targaryen you hear viserys's
voice he sounds way worse in the earlier trailer
we actually see a picture of him in later trailers
I believe this is what he's meant to look like
like he wears a mask to cover part of his face
because his leprosy has gotten so bad like in the
last episode you actually saw that he lost an arm
already so it seems like he can barely walk but
for the most part they believe that he's going to
be bedridden from here on meaning that he might
wind up dying in episode 9 like that would be a
very Ned Stark thing of him to do and we've been
talking about got him in a Ned stark context it's
kind of like ticking clock waiting for him to
die because the actual Dance of the Dragons can't
really start until he does die this is jakaris and
luceris in the yard watching somebody come through
the gate this is Daemon on Dragonstone grabbing
another dragon egg we'll see who he tries to give
it to he could be getting one for his new child
with rhaenyra remember previously he made this big
deal about getting mysaria pregnant even though
that was a lie and he tried to pretend like he was
going to give her dragon egg even though it was
a big faint he was trying to do it to get under
his brother viserys's skin this time it's for real
though he's legitimately married renera it's all
above board so he's totally free to have as many
children as he wants with her and give them all
dragon eggs the person saying this is a matter of
blood not ambition is corlys velaryons' brother
probably talking to rhaenys about the succession
this is the scene of the children fighting jakaris
aemond aegon luceris and the girls are there
too baela and rhaena like just shocked about
what's going on whatever they're arguing about
in this room here remember I said in episode 7
the whole idea that they're exploring the show in
addition to just the actual Dance of the Dragons
itself is the idea that the adults like alicent
and rhaenyra are passing this beef that they have
between them on to their children and previously
their children actually kind of liked each other
so sort of this idea that the adults are poisoning
the youth so to speak mysaria comes back into the
story she's been around this whole time it just
hasn't been a big part of what's actually going
on she's kind of like a version of larys strong
but for rhaenyra and Daemon unofficially she's
kind of like the Mistress of Whispers more like
a varys character she's a little bit less chaotic
than lyrics but she's just as deadly and I also
believe because of what's happening in the yard
here like you see aemond say nephews he's
talking to jaecaerys and lucerys it's meant
to be a callback to the events of episode 6 when
they were fighting in the yard and they were much
younger now the idea that amid has gotten way
larger like he just physically grown way bigger
and he's grown way more cruel and at the end
of the trailer in a small council meeting Otto
Hightower talks about the threat of War looming
like I said that's meant to be a reference to
the conflict heating up between the greens and the
blacks but really when he's probably talking about
in this context is actually about what's happening
in the stepstones there's also the potential that
vaman Valerian could take their forces and
also start a conflict over the battle of the
succession over driftmark as well so technically
you could talk about there being three possible
words that they have to fight if you spotted any
other Easter eggs or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
down below in the comments in my full episode 8
video will post Sunday after they released it
I do have a couple bonus videos planned for
this week too we also just got a brand new black
panther 2 trailer I'll do a video for that next
so make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that everyone click here for
my Full House of the Dragon episode 7 video and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!